so are you guys right you're at the op
right now is that true yeah
when was the last time you were there
how long has it been since you were
since you were able to
set foot in there like a month ago we
did a
media day like this and i think it was
we were the first people in i think
they let us come in here so it's been
about a month so you're not changing any
of the signage just
say rascal flats operate or anything
like that while no one else is in there
sure that's a good idea well there's
nobody here
change the whole thing and you guys are
supposed to be touring
you know saying goodbye night afternoon
of course we have the global health
crisis
that put things on hold are there still
plans to have this farewell tour once
it's safe to do so
maybe i don't know you know we're still
kind of waiting to figure it out you
know i guess
you know we're kind of on the schedule
of if there's a vaccine and what opens
and what doesn't so we could do a
vaccine to her there we go
no music just inoculations that's right
everybody can hand you up to the bar for
uh for a nice little uh shot
that's right they're uh coveted shot
that'd be great yeah man
now the ep how they remember you how do
you want to be remembered what do you
guys hope your legacy is
well you know i hope all of our fans who
all these years um
know how much we love them and
appreciate them and um how much they
were the driving force behind what made
roswell flats
nebraska flats and um i think hopefully
they
you know hopefully our music you know
has spoken for itself all these years
and maybe
it lives on way beyond us it'd be pretty
amazing that's the thing but
i think that um honestly a
big legacy piece if there is one you
know for us is
our work with vanderbilt children's
hospital i think as well
one huge solid piece of
our whole career that's been just a
blessing in our lives and
just a wonderful um appreciation we have
the hospital and um
gotten so much out of so much
fulfillment and just beautiful moments
with that hospital through these years
so
hopefully we're remembered by that too
it's amazing to be able to as a band
celebrate the 20th anniversary together
you know what is it about the way that
you guys have worked together that have
kept you guys
making music being successful and also
being able to be around each other
this whole time i think uh the music has
always come first
i think it's always been the most
important thing is serving the music and
cutting the kind of music that resonates
with our fans and hits them where they
live and
and uh inspires them um and i also feel
like
we've all we've always had this mutual
love and respect for each other that's
always been put first too
and we certainly have had our
disagreements but i think the
affection we have for one another has
superseded any of that and we found a
way to work out our differences and
realize that we're part of something
that's bigger than any one of the three
of us and and that's really kept us
grounded and kept us focused on on what
rascal flatts is and what we've built
together
and when you see the kind of impact your
music has had on the fans and you hear
there's
their stories you you start to realize
and start to know and it starts to
cement the fact that
what you've built is so much bigger than
what you are and there's a higher
commitment to that and uh i i think
that's a
testament to uh you know the hard work
we've put in
and and the love of the music that we've
had and for each other
as well now it's hard to imagine the
country music landscape without like a
regular dose of rascal flats
like it really is you you guys must plan
on
get out of telling me you're going to
plan on like working together and
collaborating continually or
do you have any plans beyond that as a
as
the unit rascal flats or what well
they've got dan and shea now
that's pretty close
i mean we really don't know you know
we've all got some different things
going on
individually and you know we'll just
have to wait and see what the future
holds and
you know hopefully down the road
something will pop up and we can
we'll do something again now speaking of
doing things individually jay you've got
your own reality tv
series with the with the family on
netflix coming up that's coming up in
august right
yeah august 19th august 19th so uh
boys are we to see cameos from you guys
in there are you going to be having like
a big viewing party for the day or what
they actually filmed it they were the
cameraman yeah we were out of a job
with this pandemic so yeah we failed you
won't see us we're behind
the camera on the other side of the
camera
actually rocky is is making a cameo in
it birthday scene little birthday
party so this is the collaborative work
you guys were talking about
beyond the music is the two of you
shooting jay's show
yeah and directing and producing yeah
do you guys have you know 20 years of
making music
um like you said getting into little
disagreements and coming back together
do you have any
regrets about anything musically over
the last 20 years any songs that you
maybe passed on
anything that you may look at and go
gosh we wish we would have done that
differently
i think i don't i you know i think that
uh
one song that stands out to me that we
passed on that that was a huge hit
is watching airplanes by gary allen that
was a really really that was pitch to us
first and for whatever reason looking
back we just didn't feel like it was
right for us and
with every project that we've ever done
there have
always been songs on there that i aren't
my personal favorites but
you know when you're in a band you make
certain allowances and certain
concessions to cut things that
you don't necessarily love all the time
but that's part of being in a band
so they're probably songs on every
record that
left to my own devices i would not have
cut
and it's probably true for all of us i'm
sure so when you look back on your
20 years of making music together you
guys um
what stands out as like your definitive
moments
like these are these are the moments
that have defined us or these are the
moments that took us to the next
level a bunch of those you know the
first
first big blip i'd have to say was i'm
moving on when that when jerry house
played that
uh we wasn't even slated to be a single
and his wife loved the song so he played
it here in nashville on morning radio
and the phones just blew up and the song
became
this huge thing that wasn't even planned
and that was the
you know we were three singles into our
career but none of the singles had
really been like
needle movers they had been you know
fine and they had been
marginal hits but once i'm moving on
came along it sort of took us
to a whole different uh place and now
that we're at
yeah sorry go on i was going to say
getting to do american idol with carrie
underwood or
the last episode of american idol that
season when she won
and we performed brooklyn road with her
and
that song just came out and like just
became this huge hit
i think a lot didn't do because i was
saying with her and the whole new
audience got to see rascal floss one
rascal classmate for the first time on
national tv
just took us to a whole other place and
now that we've gotten to how they
remember
you uh what are fans going to expect on
this how would you describe the ep and
and the journey that fans get to go on
with it
you know i think the way to describe it
is it's just kind of you know these were
actually
a lot of them are some songs that we cut
for other projects didn't have
time to get to them they didn't fit for
some reason or another but
we loved them so much that you know we
thought well let's go ahead and finish
them out
and then that's what became the ep but
um
you know i think it's i think there's
different flavors on everything i'm not
sure
you know usually it's been a ride like
like this how we kind of take them on a
musical 10 12 song
journey you know this this is shorter
and it's it's it's pieces of
uh kind of where we were at different
times
when we first heard these songs
snapshots their snapshots is what they
are they're
they're mindful blips um
yeah and so i think it's you know i
think you'll hear some
you know some pop flavors to the thomas
rhett stuff to the country or stuff to
so it's just kind of encompasses kind of
you know all the stuff that we really
love musically
yeah well guys you can say you know one
silver lining of this
you guys not being on tour currently
that the fans get to hold on a little
bit longer
before they uh before they get to say
goodbye to you in all those venues right
yeah man hopefully everybody stays well
stays healthy and
you know we'll all get through this
together we will we'll get through this
together and then
you know we'll figure out what the
future holds and we'll go from there
you